boycotter l'année dernière emmanuel
macron renoue donc avec cette tradition
ses voeux à la presse à l'elysée le chef
de l'état qui a évoqué on vient de voir
plusieurs sujets pendant cette
allocution peut-être pour recréer du
lien avec les journalistes pourront
communiquer pour rassurer avec peut-être
aussi en ligne de mire la présidentielle
de 2022 c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
mais côté didier maïsto président de sud
radio bonsoir didier mais l'essentiel
est là
guy konopnicki journaliste à marianne
merci à vous également d'être là alors
emmanuel macron finalement qui est un
peu changé d'avis je ne sais pas si ce
cas d'accord avec cette analyse
c'est bien plus stratégique évidemment
il ya un an voilà il voulait discuter
directement avec les français sans
passer par les journalistes les lieux le
grand débat et puis là tout d'un coup il
dit voilà le début du quinquennat a
nourri des malentendus et il s'exprime
devant la presse
sartre a au pédalage stratégie que guy
konopnicki oui c'est vrai que d'une
manière générale il a découvert les
corps d'un terme les corps
intermédiaires sûr que j'ai une bouche
loyal et syndicats vous pensez faire
toutes les réformes en passant par
dessus les syndicats de ces ratés quand
même ça ne marche pas mais la même chose
aussi avec les élus les élus locaux
alors on
on a vu pendant la crise et le gros de
la crise de gilet jaune est allé vers
les mers il est allé vers l'est il avait
besoin d'eux pour organiser son débat il
vient vers les journalistes
moi je pense qu'il a commencé par un
vous plaît qui est très grave
mes yeux c'est que c'est un anniversaire
que nous n'avons pas pu célébrer à sa
juste mesure en raison des
manifestations il ya cinq ans douze
collaborateurs d'un journal tomberait
dans leur rédaction
à charlie hebdo je pense que présentant
ses voeux à la presse le président de la
république devait parler des libertés de
la presse et rendent hommage à ceux qui
sont tombés pour elle
est ce que je trouve significatif c'est
qu'un peu plus loin quand il parle alors
vous dit des choses très bien on espère
que ce soit du vide est suivie d'effet
sur notre conception du droit d'auteur
sur les gens d'ailleurs insitent ai dit
vous êtes auteur journalistes ou
photographes dessinateurs se présente
dessinateur 1 il y à des dessinateurs
chênois marianne c'est inde un des mois
deux à des modes d'expression important
mais voilà il ya les dessinateurs tombé
il ya cinq ans dont
l'un était à charlie et à marianne mais
peu importe les quatre qui compte
évidemment c'est quand même oublier ça
dans la liste des professions qui font
la presse
c'est une amitié vous vous êtes une
omission d'aujourd'hui c'est maîtrisé
c'est des gens qui lisent les journaux
qui aiment les journaux n'oublie pas çà
et là on a cette culture technocratique
où on lit le lis pas la presse on il les
notes de ses collaborateurs selon qu'il
ya des années qui lui restent à quai les
collaborateurs bien avant d'être
président quand il était ministre quand
il était à l'elysée auprès des landes
ces gens arrivent à leur bureau et puis
il ya le petit bloc qui est légal et les
articles choisis
jadis découpe est aujourd'hui sorti sur
imprimante
voilà ce que vous devez savoir
aujourd'hui mais cette relation avec le
journal
didier s'amarrer incroyable qui est
cette omission effectivement ça dit
quelque chose dit confronté le relevé à
juste titre ça paraît effectivement
incroyable qui ait pas une mention sur
ses confrères à tuer s'est dit quelque
chose d' emmanuel macron qui est
quelqu'un effectivement qui découvre la
vie dans les notes quand on a l'odeur du
papier
quand on a attaché charnellement
pratiquement un journal quand on sait
qu'en france on peut mourir pour faire
un dessin caricature et que c'est
complètement biffés au mit pas cité dans
le discours du président de la
république
évidemment c'est une première chose qui
est choquant d'ailleurs ici ce soir nous
n'existons pas puisque si j'ai bien
suivi du président la république il ya
une presse professionnelle qui a une
imprimatur jeunes au tri crt ont fait un
acte courageux et séditieux puisque rt
même s'il n'a pas cité la russie il l'a
quand même évoqué puisqu'il a parlé de
manipulation c'est bien ce que ça veut
dire pendant la campagne présidentielle
donc aujourd'hui finalement ils essaient
de s'appuyer sur des gens qui sont assez
docile qui l'ont fait élire qu'ils ont
mis en une de tous les magazines qui ne
se rebelle pas beaucoup
et j'aurais bien aimé un hommage à tous
les vidéastes amateurs parce qu'il est
elle a balayé comme ça il a méprisé
il les a niées il les a insultés ça fait
un an plus d'un an y en a plutôt parlé
ensemble méfiance c'est bien plus que ça
on va écouter c'est pas avec un
téléphone portable messi ou étaient les
journalistes men cim qui a pris des
risques qui s'est pris des tirs de l bd
qui s'est pris des gaz lacrymogènes et
des grenades jl icade et des grenades
jet li f4 certainement pas les
journalistes mènent suivent les
journalisme streamiz arrivé le matin il
disait à personne il repartait le soir
ils essaient violent voilà ce qui s'est
justement il a fait mention en tout ces
deux éléments au début de son discours
on va l'écouter 1 il a tenu à rappeler
que lors des manifestations des gilet
jaune auquel vous faites allusion les
journées ça avait été protégé par les
forces de l'ordre par aman vous n'avez
pas assez rappelé son souviennent
important de réguler et réglementée on
va écouter nous ne devons pas être fermé
par principe à ce que de grands acteurs
économiques y compris étrangers
investissent dans la presse française
il est des titres pour lesquels cela
fonctionne parfaitement
nous devons veiller en revanche à ce que
toutes les garanties soit au rendez-vous
pour protéger le pluralisme de
l'information l'indépendance des
rédactions et finalement défendre cette
presse souveraine et libre qui est la
marque des grandes nations en 2019 la
loi bichet a été modifié en ce sens de
sorte que les sociétés de distribution
depuis cette contrôlé à plus de 20% par
les intérêts étrangers non
communautaires dans la même lignée grâce
à un décret du ministre de l'économie
publié le 1er janvier la presse est
désormais inclus dans le contrôle des
investissements étrangers ce qui
implique un régime d'autorisation
préalable est très protecteur et quel
que soit le statut des investisseurs
continueront à veiller à l'indépendance
journalistique et à éviter toute forme
de concentration qui viendraient
justement mettre en péril cette
indépendance et je suis sûr que
des débats continueront de voir le jour
dans les prochains mois sur ce sujet qui
nous amèneront collectivement à
poursuivre la réflexion et de travail
des journalistes au moment de la crise
dite des filets jaunes ont été protégés
par les forces de l'ordre parce qu'ils
étaient journalistes
et je ne vous ai pas entendu le rappeler
je pense que c'est important de
d'apporter cette clarification et c'est
bien normal dans une démocratie mais ça
veut dire que nombre de nos concitoyens
est alors considéré que les journalistes
étaient devenus des ennemis parce qu'il
ne disait pas ce que voulait entendre ou
que ne disait pas une vérité qui était
la leur ou celle qu'ils partageaient sur
leurs réseaux sociaux preuve s'il en est
toutefois que toutes les informations ne
se valent pas parce qu'elles n'ont pas
forcément toutes le statut d'information
ce qui surviendrait sur ce sujet ce qui
veut bien dire que quelque part il faut
réguler ou réglementé et d'ailleurs
votre profession a toujours vécu dans la
régulation réglementation qu'il s'agisse
de la liberté elle-même comme du modèle
économique
enlevez la régulation pardon de le dire
il n'y a plus un titre jane présent qui
existent donc ne vous trompez pas à
combattre peut-être trop rapidement
toute forme de régulation
historiquement elle vous a protégé et le
continuera de le faire et le sujet que
j'évoque est un sujet de protection un
didier maïsto ça doit vous faire plaisir
là ces deux sorties disons que nous ne
vivons pas dans le même pays
moi ce que j'ai vu parce que peut-être
je suis pas sous les ors de la
république mais plutôt que de partir en
week-end ou à la mongie jeu le week end
je suis avec les gens dans la rue pour
voir ce qui s'y passe donc moi j'ai bien
sûr qu'il ya quelques policiers qui ont
protégé des journalistes au début des
actes d gilet jaune parce que les
joueurs et gilet jaune était furieux de
voir toutes ces fausses informations
divulguées à la fois sur la manière de
se comporter les forces de l'ordre sur
le comptage de des manifestants ou
encore sur le fait d'être affublé de
tous les maux de la terre antisémites
racistes homophobes
j'en passe et des meilleurs tout ça par
les journalistes mais elle suit mais les
éditorialistes les plus en vue ou les
pseudo philosophe les 6000
philosophe pour reprendre la
terminologie de monsieur le président de
la république
moi j'ai surtout vu des journalistes
indépendants embarqué par les forces de
l'ordre c'est encore arrivé à rémy
buisine
il ya quelques jours j'ai vu un certain
nombre de journalistes violentes et des
journalistes américains les jours non
non non non c'est pas ça non mais s'est
blessé
vous m'interrogez langage objet orange
elle agit sur la sur la séquence
on nous ne vivons pas manifestement dans
le même pays
guy et inconnus qui pourraient sur la
régulation geste e rang sur la
régulation
on a toujours vécu avec un encadrement
légal transgresser c'est à dire que la
presse qui est longtemps régie par les
ordonnances 44 de 1944 à perdre et la
constitution de groupes
vous aviez le groupe hersant le groupe
lagardère le groupe s'appuie donc de
toutes façons on l'a venez vous ensuite
les investisseurs étrangers ont les
meilleurs étrangers communautaires pas
communautaire marianne fait partie de
l'ensemble de le genou dans lequel 1 1
nous avons un investisseur un
investisseur tchèque depuis les
communautaires tout où l'avion on est
dans la colonne nord dans la communauté
européenne
je crois que le problème de la
dépendance n'est pas et de
l'indépendance de la presse n'est pas
forcément le régime de
d'un 6 heures que soient italiens turcs
anglais ou ou qui viennent ou qui
viennent de plus loin c'est son activité
or nous avons eu quand même un rapport
un peu fort entre nous avons toujours
des investisseurs qui dépendent de
l'état d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est ça lorsqu'ils sont dans dans la
construction dans l'armement en salle
c'est complètement hors ceux là sont les
investisseurs français de lait vont dans
lequel il ya de très bons journaux et
des rédactions qui se bat qui défendent
leur indépendance de lennon un truc mais
nous avons quand même toujours eu une
question d'armer la teda effectivement
c'est celui ci c'est sûrement parce que
c'est une son ennui les investisseurs
riches ni les investisseurs
extracommunautaire eaux communautaires
ces deux qui dépend leur fortune de qui
dépend ils sont petits en affaires
publiques avec l'état si vous vendez des
télés loggia d'ailleurs osé les moyens
de pression c'est que dans ce désert
d'aidé du fait des travaux publics vous
vendez des deux vous voulez de la
téléphonie c'est très compliqué ensuite
de s'absoudre et d'être et de se dire
indépendant la vraie indépendance comme
disait l'autre consiste à savoir de qui
on dépense qui en dépend ce qui
complique les choses c'est que nous
sommes dans un système multimédia ou
donc on va trouver et bat tous les
opérateurs de téléphonie on va trouver
qui sont effectivement tous dans tout
dans l'audiovisuel puisque aujourd'hui
le lien entre l'audiovisuel et le
numérique le portable est là c'est là
qu'il faut travailler c'est là que le
législateur de travail et concertée la
profession comprendre comment ça se
passe et comment on peut défendre
l'indépendance de l'information
d'indépendance du journalisme dans un
monde numérique qui est dominée
et par trois quatre cinq multinationales
et avec des groupes français avec voilà
c'est ça c'est la vraie question la
république d'ailleurs il voulait un
conseil de déontologie des médias
annonceurs rencontre je trompe en disant
que même les médias les grands médias
français leur ton tourner le dos à ce
conseil le noble s'est envolé ce
contrôle est soi même c'est toujours un
petit peu compliqué les ordres
professionnels on se pensait bien kwassa
kwassa abouti premièrement deuxièmement
si le présent la république veut une
presse indépendante l'indépendance à se
décrète pas l'indépendance ça se vérifie
qu qu'ils laissent les médias tranquille
et puis à le jugement des lecteurs des
internautes et téléspectateurs des
auditeurs en cinq ans on avait seulement
qu'au début on line cette histoire d'un
conseil de conseil de déontologie
on n'est ni avocat ni médecin ni jeu
je n'ai pas moi à contrôler la
déontologie des confrères si je pense
que un article n'est pas bon dans le
figaro je me réponds donc fait entendre
au journal
c'est c'est comme ça que ça se passe
l'amiante heures j'étais présidente sc
des réacteurs à une époque à marianne la
déontologie ça se contrôle de
l'intérieur avec un système qui est
assez répandu dans beaucoup de types tue
celui des sociétés d'injecteurs par
exemple par exemple et il y en a
d'autres
il ya d'autre systèmes il y à des
endroits où il ya un médiateur
déontologue souci c'est la faire de
chaque entreprise
ça n'est pas le seul pas être à faire
dans un espèce de truc puyoô de poils et
désigné comment il y aura des
représentants de l'état y aurait qu il
nous a alors décidé si c'est si c'est un
vote mais alors on fait comment mais
pour résumer à t-il dit aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui est important pour bien
comprendre l'essence la nature du
discours les tenants et les aboutissants
il a dit finalement il ya des
journalistes professionnels quand une
carte professionnelle etc
je leur donne mon imprimatur et je leur
ai demandé de réfléchir
il a dit il est employé le nous nous
allons organiser l'indépendance déjà
c'est suspect quand
on est quand on est censé être un
contre-pouvoir d'avoir l'exécutif
l'elysée qui vous dit nous allons
organiser votre indépendance
moi je pars mon premier réflexe c'est de
partir en courant volée j'ai pas besoin
de l'état pour qu'il me dise comment je
dois écrire comment je dois penser
qu'elles doivent être nommé auditeur et
sait déjà c'est un problème des diamants
nos risques on les prend on les prend
nos risques on embauche des gens on
investit on se défonce matin midi et
soir et on a le jugement du public
que voulez-vous de plus et si les gens
ne sont pas contents il ya une loi qui
est très bien
elle est perfectible mais tellement
seule 881 il vole à relire
on est passé d'un contrôle a priori
préventif à une répression a posteriori
pénale c'est à dire qu'on peut se
défendre
c'est à dire qu'on puisse qu'il peut y
avoir l'exception de vérité on peut
ça suffit pour la deux jours m entre la
justice et les citoyens des organismes
soit disant indépendants qui vont dicter
le bon et le mauvais sens bien et ça
c'est une dérive très intérieure c'est
incroyable c'est une dérive très
inférieures à l'élection des bagnoles
macron c'est-à-dire très anti registre
d'interrogation fini par autoriser la
fin du débat est ce que vous vous avez
quelques années métier est ce que il ya
vraiment une spécificité des relations
journalistes presse en tout cas
président avec le président mais cros
c'est pas forcément le cas
écoutez il ya des mutations ont apprécié
à une époque où les journaux ne jugaient
rien de plus important que d'avoir
quelqu'un qui ne lâche pas le président
de la république et donc c'est c'est eh
on se battait pour les places dans les
voyages par où je m'inclus page tao un
personnel parce que je suspect battu
pour ça j'ai au contraire invités mais
bon on se battait les journaux pour
avoir les places des bonnes places dans
les avions présidentiels les avions du
premier ministre dans les voyages t'as
pas tellement pour le but du voyage et
l'endroit qu'on avait on avait visité
mais mais mais pour écouter les
confidences pour parler ça on jouera que
ce temps là et est un peu fini d'abord
parce que les informations vous
vos vraies fausses bonnes mauvaises mais
de toute façon elles vont beaucoup plus
vite et donc il ya des choses qu'on sait
plane et aussi parce que il y a un état
d'esprit qui a changé chez journalistes
et en bien là de ce point de vue qui
était l'idée am il faut absolument
répercuter penser en avant la phrase
qu'il insistait d'ailleurs sur l'ironie
de gaulle qui disait je vais lire je
vais dire ce que je pense
quand j'ouvre jorrand le matin et
souvent les élections je suis pas
d'accord ça c'est une c'est un autre
temps de le nôtre à beaucoup d'autres
défauts mais mais mais ça c'est plutôt
en train de passer cette espèce de
journalistes de prétendus fréquentant
les milieux bien informés
[Musique]
l'armée semble tellement mal informés
effectivement si vous voulez faire
vraiment bouger pas de leçon à donner
mais on eu d'expérience c'est pas dans
les conférences de presse
c'est pas dans les cocktails n'est pas
dans les avions présidentiels ce n'est
pas dans les chambres d'hôtel ce n'est
pas en vacances n'est pas au théâtre
avec des hommes politiques fusse-t-il
célèbre est en vue vous allez faire
votre boulot de journaliste nous on aime
je suis invité à tous je ne vais rien
vous ne verrez jamais dans un cocktail
vous ne verrez jamais dans une mondanité
et c'est parce que je veux garder
d'abord mon indépendance
mon libre arbitre ma capacité à
critiquer dans le bon sens comme dans le
mauvais si je copine c'est fini c'est
quoi cette histoire d'abord lundi matin
sous 10 jours avec la nes il ya des
informations vous savez très bien
comment on fait des enquêtes ça marche
pas comme ça mais je sais c'est pas
comme ça c'est le piège parce que si
vous pensez qu'un homme politique va
vous donner un scoop en off et c'est le
nom politique et dans sa stratégie
il veut être réélu il veut briller de
suiveux plaire etc
si on est là c'est de la communication
ces traits du jour d'héroïsme et la
différence elle est là et cet exercice
compassée de la conférence de presse de
presse à l'elysée il est vraiment qu'on
passait sans mauvais jeu de mots
c'est pas là qu'il était dans la
séduction aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
vous l'avez trouvé justement est ce
qu'il renoue finalement celui qui
voulait éviter ça est-ce qu'il est
retombé là dedans dans ce côté se
refaire une image vis-à-vis des
journalistes dont il aura certainement
besoin bientôt un an ça déjà me ça a
déjà marché
ceci dit vous trouvez obama avant son
élection ça a marché
oui mais là vous voyez le nombre le
nombre d'eux un nombre de reportages
c'est ce qui a marché peut remarcher
notre situation est tellement dos ils
dansent pas marcher jusqu'à parler quand
même c'était la nouveauté on a assisté
un spectacle extravagant qui était
l'effondrement simultané des deux partis
politiques qui ont alterné au pouvoir
depuis 1980 avant puisque les autres
étaient là avant son revenu non on à
l'effondrement simultané et il ya ce
personnage qui monte qui brusquement il
aimerait bien ses balles génération ça
n'était pas réseau évidemment organisé
évident avec une conférence de passe
toute la journée sur sur france info
tous les toutes les 15 minutes il va
parler attention il va par les
roulements de tambour il a parlé voilà
ce qu'il a dit dans l'autre sens assez
bien finie donc d'abord ça a marché mais
ça a marché dans un contexte qui n'est
pas celui exclusivement de la
communication c'est un contexte
politique alors qu'elle sera un vrai
qu'elle soit le quel est le contexte
politique aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle sera
t-il au lendemain des municipales
qu'est ce qui ne sera quand on sera dans
la dernière ligne droite de l'élection
présidentielle que les candidatures sont
déclarés j'en sais rien j'en sais rien
fait rien personne ça sera le mot de la
fin merci messieurs l'idée mais le dos
guy konopnicki d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france